if you had to eat one human body part
what would it be
I mean these who wrote These the
internet boys boys wrote that
again no
um I need something small I don't want
to eat a lot of Flesh probably like a
little toe toes you need a toe it's like
I'm not Feeder first of all I'm not
asking to eat a body part you have made
me answer a question I'm not saying some
sort of like low-hanging fruit like some
sort of thing so I'm taking the smallest
I'll tell you I think you're the only
person who's made it because I'm the
first girl no guys can be like you want
me to do it
like everyone knows compared to like a
chicken and been like a thigh a breast
why are you gonna eat such a big piece I
could get a little toe down in one
swallow no that's gross but we're not
talking about a cow we're talking about
I have to get down one human part you
know you don't like it
how do you know I don't like a toe
I thought you had a taste listen bye
it's very broy around here I don't know
what's going on